c'est vraiment ce que c'est la logique
si le gic est la logique c'est la
connexion naturelle entre les choses si
des choses sont connectés est
logiquement ça veut dire qu elles
s'enchaînent régulièrement et
nécessairement par exemple si je couvre
mon oeil
avec ma main je ne vois plus que c'était
l'action de poser ma main sur monoï
entraîne à chaque fois et sans exception
possible
l'incapacité de l'oeil il existe donc un
lien logique entre les deux c'est
logique ce type d lien est très
important en dissertation parce que ce
sont ces liens qui permettent de passer
rigoureusement d'une idée à une autre
c'est à dire de faire avancer la
réflexion
[Musique]
dans l'absolu les connecteurs logique
sont la marque d'un mauvais style oui
parce que les critiques littéraires
considère que l'enchaînement des idées
doit être naturel au point qu'il n'est
pas besoin d'être renforcée
artificiellement
dit plus simplement si on exprime ses
idées clairement alors le lecteur
comprendra facilement les connexions
logique qui existent entre elles
c'est logique qui est le bon tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord avec les
critiques littéraires et puis les ai
toutes expérimental sur la lecture
montre que les lecteurs préfèrent les
textes avec des liens logiques mais
surtout si les connecteurs logique sous
la marque d'un mauvais style c'est dans
l'absolu or une dissertation
ce n'est pas n'importe quel texte ce
n'est pas un roman ni un article vous
savez peut-être déjà le correcteur va
vous lire très rapidement les qualités
de votre rédaction doivent donc être
grossière afin qu'elle saute aux yeux
lors d'une lecture expéditif
et dans cette perspective les
connecteurs logique sont très utiles
parce qu'ils servent a décuplé
l'impression de cohérence de votre
propos c'est à dire que s'il ya beaucoup
de liens logiques dans votre
dissertation le correcteur aura
l'impression que vos idées s'enchaînent
bien vous avez donc intérêt à utiliser
beaucoup de connecteurs logique en
dissertation ce n'est donc pas étonnant
qu'il y en ai plein dans les bonnes
copies mais si vous voulez être capable
de rédiger une bonne dissertation
vous avez d'abord besoin d'une bonne
méthode est bien juste qu'il vous faut
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie le lien doit s'afficher
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
mais on pouvait aussi le trouver dans la
description de cette vidéo c'est un
cours par e-mail donc vous pourrez le
découvrir plus tard à la fin de cette
vidéo ou dans les prochains jours là
tout de suite
rester concentré sur cette vidéo
regardez-la attentivement jusqu'au bout
et vous saurez comment utiliser les
connecteurs logique en dissertation vous
pouvez saisir le correcteur et gagner
facilement aux des points dès votre
prochaine dissertation
[Musique]
j'aurais dit les connecteurs logique
certes a créé une grossière impression
de cohérence en dissertation
mais dans le détail il y à différentes
manières de le faire sur le fond
tout d'abord vous devez distinguer deux
types de connexions logique une
connexion peut lier deux idées mais elle
peut aussi servir à développer une idée
c'est à dire à fournir des informations
plus précises que votre esprit peut
ranger dans l'idée plus générale alors
je pourrais continuer à vous en parler
parce que c'est un sujet qui me
passionne
la manipulation des idées mais ça va
devenir compliqué ça ne sera pas
rentable pour vous c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas grâce à ça que vous allez
gagner rapidement des points en
dissertation donc
rappelez-vous simplement que sur le fond
un lien logique peut servir soit allié
deux idées soit à développer une idée
maintenant quel est le rôle des
connecteurs logique du point de vue de
la forme un lien logique que tout
d'abord servir à connecter de
proposition dans une même phrase
par exemple je m'entraîne à la salle de
sport bien que je n'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
dans cette phrase la conjonction de
subordination bien que exprime
l'opposition entre le fait de
s'entraîner à la salle de sports et
celui de ne pas avoir dormi de la nuit
parce qu'après une enseigne et on n'a
pas beaucoup d'énergie je parle
d'expérience dont gagna logique peut
connecter de proposition dans une même
phrase mais il peut aussi connecter deux
phrases complètes
par exemple je suis très fatigué en
raison d'une insomnie
je m'entraîne tout de même à la salle de
sports dans ce cas c'est la locution
adverbiale de la seconde phrase tout de
même qu'ils expriment l'opposition entre
l'effort de s'entraîner à la salle des
sports et l'insomnie
alors vous avez intérêt à utiliser les
collecteurs logique à la fois à
l'intérieur et entre les phrases mais la
priorité c'est de lier les phrases entre
elles parce que ça facilite la lecture
du correcteur en terme de fréquence je
vous recommande d'utiliser un connecteur
logique par phrase est de varier sa
place dans la phrase un coup au début un
coup au milieu sans cette variation le
rythme de vos phrases sera haché
et monotone regardez ces deux phrases en
effet je suis fatigué en raison d'une
insomnie
pourtant je m'entraîne à la salle de
sport pour améliorer le rythme il suffit
de déportés l'adverbe pourtant au milieu
de la seconde phrase ça donne en effet
je suis fatigué en raison d'une insomnie
je m'entraîne pourtant à la salle de
sports alors je suis d'accord c'est un
détail mais lorsqu'il s'accumule
les détails commencent à peser et puis
comme vous le savez la clarté de
l'expression écrite est survalorisé en
dissertation
voilà maintenant que vous connaissez les
deux rôles des liens logiques en
dissertation
je vais vous montrer les connecteurs que
vous pouvez utiliser je commence par le
premier type de connecteur logique ce
qui lie deux idées si vous voulez lier
deux idées vous avez à votre disposition
cinq types principaux de connecteurs
logique le premier type ce sont les
connecteurs logique d'opposition
je ne vais pas les énumérer vous pouvez
voir une liste indicative à l'écran lien
logique de position sont les plus utiles
en dissertation parce que l'opposition
et la nature même de la tension
dialectique
en effet pour que la réflexion soit
fructueuse il faut penser contre soi
même
vous aurez donc tout particulièrement
besoin des liens logiques d'opposition
dans l' annonce de plan puisque les
grandes parties du plan de la
dissertation sont articulés logiquement
le deuxième type de connecteur logique
qui sert à connecter des idées ce sont
les connecteurs logique de cause ce type
de connecteur logique est également très
utile en dissertation parce que comme le
dit rousseau la résolution de tout
problème commence par la recherche des
causes moi j'utilise surtout les liens
logiques de cause suivant
le troisième type ce sont les
connecteurs logique de conséquences la
conséquence est elle aussi importante
parce qu'elle constitue l' inverse
logique de la cause si à la cause du bea
lors b est la conséquence de à
j'aime bien les connecteurs logique de
conséquence suivant le quatrième type de
connecteur logique qui sert à connecter
deux idées ce sont les connecteurs
logique d'addition alors l'addition
c'est pas super comme mia logique parce
qu'elle n'est pas vraiment logique au
sens strict deux idées additionner ne
sont pas intrinsèquement connectés moi
je préfère les liens logiques d'addition
suivant essayé de ne pas trop utiliser
ses liens parce qu'ils peuvent donner
l'impression aux correcteurs que vous
empilez les idées plutôt que de les
connecter logiquement
enfin le cinquième type de connecteur
logique qui sert à connecter des idées
ce sont les connecteurs logique de
conclusion ils sont moins utile que les
précédents mais ils servent quand même
parce que si vous exposez votre
réflexion avec méthode
alors vous devez résumé les résultats de
votre réflexion à différentes étapes
typiquement à la fin d'un paragraphe ou
dans une conclusion partielle
voici les liens logiques de conclusion
que j'utilise voilà vous connaissez
maintenant les cinq connecteurs logique
qui certes alliés
deux idées les liens logiques
d'opposition de cause de conséquence
d'addition et enfin de conclusion
maintenant je vais vous parler des
connecteurs logique qui servent à
développer une idée
[Musique]
pour commencer je vous rappelle que
développer une idée ça signifie fournir
des informations plus précises qui sont
en rapport avec l'idée d'accords pour
faire ça vous pouvez utiliser trois
types de connecteurs logique
le premier type ce sont les connecteurs
logique de précisions ce type de
connecteur logique me sert surtout à
indiquer que la phrase a pour fonction
de creuser l'idée de la précédente
jésus utilise donc davantage à
l'intérieur des paragraphes
je préfère les liens logiques de
précision suivant le deuxième type de
connecteur logique qui sait à développer
une idée ce sont les connecteurs logique
d'énumération alors comme les élèves
elles les connaissent moins je vous
donne un exemple
ma méthode de dissertation comporte sept
étapes
en premier lieu je réfléchisse au sujet
de manière stratégique
je cherche ensuite des exemples pour un
délimiter le champ etc
je me sers surtout des connecteurs
logique d'énumération pour rédiger les
introductions partiel et les premières
phrases des paragraphes fait c'est une
solution simple pour indiquer aux
correcteurs où ils se situent dans la
progression la réflexion en pratique
vous devez d'abord présenté la première
idée du développement avec un des liens
suivants
ensuite vous énumérer les idées
suivantes avec les autres types de
connecteurs logique enfin le troisième
type de liens logiques qui sert à
développer une idée ce sont les
connecteurs logique d'illustration ce
type de connecteur logique sert
généralement à passer du niveau abstrait
au niveau concret et sont
particulièrement utiles à l'intérieur
des paragraphes j'utilise en priorité
les liens logiques d'illustration
suivant voilà vous connaissez maintenant
les trois types de liens logiques qui
servent à développer une idée et
connecteurs logique de précision des
numérations et enfin d'illustration vous
savez maintenant comment utiliser les
connecteurs logique en dissertation
logiquement la prochaine étape de cette
vidéo c'est la conclusion
[Musique]
alors comme dans une bonne dissertation
je vais vous rappeler ce que vous avez
appris dans cette vidéo
en résumé vous avez appris trois choses
la première chose c'est que sur le fond
les connecteurs logique certes soit
allié deux idées souhaite à développer
une idée sur la forme vous pouvez les
utiliser soit à l'intérieur d'une même
phrase pour connecter deux propositions
soit pour connecter deux phrases
différentes
la deuxième chose que vous avez apprise
dans cette vidéo ce sont les cinq types
de connecteurs logique qui servent à
lier deux idées un lien logique
d'opposition de cause de conséquence
d'addition et enfin de conclusion et
enfin la troisième chose que vous avez
apprises
ce sont les trois types de connecteurs
logique qui certes a développé une idée
et connecteurs logique de précision des
numérations et enfin d'illustration si
vous suivez les conseils que je vous ai
donné dans cette vidéo vous vous
améliorez en dissertation
mais vous savez bien que les connecteurs
logique ça reste un détail
ce n'est pas l'essentiel pour réussir
une dissertation si le gic ce qui est
essentiel c'est d'avoir une méthodologie
solide
je vous invite donc à vous inscrire pour
recevoir mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation souhaite
en cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de
vidéo voilà voilà j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu et puisqu'elle vous
sera utile je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote qui
est monté sur la table et vous étiez sur
mille de culture générale rappelez vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour utiliser efficacement les
connecteurs logique en dissertation
[Musique]